I would start this with a gag about how
there's nothing worth saying about
street fighters The Legend of chun-li
but I'm gonna be talking for like 20
minutes straight so here we go
street fighter The Legend of chun-li a
massive failure of intense Street
Fighter The Legend of chun-li is a very
odd film it feels like an honest attempt
to taking the video game adaptation and
elevating it to the same level of
respect as literary adaptations and does
so by mimicking the Transformers now
this isn't to say that the literary
adaptation is inherently high-class
there are definitely greater and lesser
adaptations out there on one hand you
have adaptations like annihilation that
while not strictly faithful to the
original text capture the spirit of the
novel in a way that takes advantage of
the change in medium and on the other
hand you have stuff like Earth's II like
the dragon the ravaged enemy that's the
one you remember it's to day one to find
it
I want to subdue it to whilst you can
ask it anything question if you desire
yes but that specific spread in quality
and the sheer volume of adaptations that
have been made means that a movie based
on a book tends to get a pretty fair
shake critically the presuppositions
created by the phrase based on the
best-selling novel are broadly neutral
trending towards positive the same
cannot be said for the phrase based on
the hit video game the pursuit of the
respectable video game movie has
remained elusive but boy our Studios
still trying to Marais der and
Assassin's Creed would be the most
recent failed attempts at securing some
prestige but let's roll back a decade
it's 2009 the PlayStation 3 and Xbox 360
air hits and high-definition gaming is
no longer next-gen it's the standard
blockbuster videogames are investing
more and more in narrative genres that
would have previously done little more
than pointed the player in a direction
and just said yeah
just shoot the dudes in red are
expecting to have a campaign laden with
pathos melodrama full voice acting and
mocap facial animation simultaneously
so-called nerd culture has surged into
the mainstream with the better part of
the decade being dominated by huge geek
franchises such as Harry Potter the Lord
of the Rings Star Wars and transformers
dominating the box office and to a large
degree the cultural zeitgeist itself in
2009 capcom tried to capitalize on this
apparent respectability by turning
street fighter' into an arty crime drama
by copying the Transformers it did not
work I love this job
while the dramatic qualities of Michael
Bay's 2007 transformers have been the
subject of endless ridicule and
criticism the spectacle still resonated
with audiences and those box-office
profits definitely resonated with
investors from aspect ratio to color
palette to story structure everything
about Legend of chun-li is the budget
friendly version same aspect ratio but
using spherical lenses instead of
expensive Troublesome anamorphic lenses
same color palette but in broad washed
tones instead of an expensive
frame-by-frame color grade same plot
structure with a superfluous troop cop
be plot that only collides with the a
plot at the very end it's actually kind
of unsettling the degree to which Legend
of chun-li is clearly cribbing from
Michael Bay's notes all part of an
attempt at coding itself as a real movie
it even aspires to a similar weight and
intensity not just action but capital D
drama which brings us to the other
primary influence angley's Crouching
Tiger on some level this project started
as Crouching Tiger they wanted Legend of
chun-li to be a martial arts action
movie that was at its core a character
driven drama much like Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon that's not a bad goal all
told and a character like chun-li isn't
a bad choice if that's the story you
want to tell within the Street Fighter
universe chun-li is easily one of the
more accessible characters
she's a martial artist who works for
Interpol she's out to avenge her
father's death
and that's about it unlike a lot of
other characters from the games you
don't have to expose it a deep mythology
explained magic powers or introduced
dozens of other core characters in order
to tell her basic story it is a
straightforward origins and revenge plot
which frees you up to really focus on
character and story a good cue to the
dramatic intent of the film is in the
specifics of the editing the movie
starts with a glory shot of the Golden
Gate Bridge which pans over to Kidd
Chumley playing piano and her father
watching proudly while adult Chumley
narrates overtop ruminating on her
childhood dream of being a concert
pianist this moment lasts almost a
minute and has only two edits for a very
quick insert from there the film cuts
into a much faster paced sequence of
aerial shots of Hong Kong and the music
changes from relaxed piano too tense
electro rock both the editor and the
cinematographer are working to bring us
into Chumley's emotional space they want
us to share her viewpoint and understand
the contrast in her life the peace and
serenity of her early years in San
Francisco versus the uncertainty and
chaos of Hong Kong
this is solid fundamental filmmaking so
what's the problem
oh boy is the script terrible that is
not the only problem but if we were to
point to a singular core issue that's
what went wrong with Crouching pianist
hidden street fighter the script sucks
the performances leave a lot to be
desired but it's hard to give a powerful
performance when the script consists of
gems like this
my father was an important businessman
was a very well-connected businessman
Kristin Kreuk sounds like she's reading
a bedtime story to a three year old
witch yeah sure a great way to really
elevate your video game movie is to
condescend to the audience like their
actual children sure yeah with my mother
gone the path in front of me was empty I
couldn't help feeling like I was being
led somewhere new I'm actually willing
to bet that this voice-over like many a
terrible narrator passed was a late
addition once they realized the plot was
not particularly compelling on its own
merits and audiences were having trouble
following the set up because it's boring
however Kruk condescending narration is
not the least of the scripts problems
for some brevity let's just make it into
a list of major flaws though I'm not
going to be able to get to all of these
one terrible dialogue - villain with
unclear goals and motivations three
poorly explained stakes for multiple
extraneous characters with dead end plot
lines five main character learns nothing
worthwhile and does not change six
changes are made to the source material
that actively make the story worse and 7
inconsistent moral core in a movie about
doing the right thing and that is the
bottom line that we're going to dig into
here this movie sucks because the script
is terrible let's talk about that plot
shall we as a young child chun-li wants
to be a concert pianist her family moves
from San Francisco to Hong Kong she is
taught wushu by her father however at a
young age her father is kidnapped by
bison played here by Neal McDonough
doing his best to try and set himself
apart from ral Julia's sublime
performance of the character by acting
the character with a little thing Irish
brogue next time you move tell me I
bring you a housewarming gift chun-li
grows up and does become a concert
pianist then after a performance one
night she receives an ancient scroll as
a gift from an unknown person on her way
home she sees a man with a spider web
tattoo on his hand get mugged in the
subway and she calls for help but no one
comes and then the scene just ends this
is the kind of moment that isn't going
to stand out on the first viewing
because you mentally assume that they're
gonna fill in down the line but they
don't I am despite multiple viewings
hard-pressed to explain the point or
purpose of this mugging scene moving on
Chumley's mom dies of cancer bison has
his business partners killed for no
discernible reason bison menaces
chun-li's father who he has stashed away
in a basement somewhere doing something
after her mother's funeral Chumlee gets
her scroll read and the woman tells her
she needs to find a man named again
who's the guy with the spider web tattoo
and then I guess Chumlee becomes
homeless in Thailand because that's her
plan to find again this isn't well
explained at all a lot changes very
quickly and none of her friends or
family seem concerned that she's
quitting her job in moving to Bangkok on
a whim shortly following the death of
her mother without making any prior
arrangements for housing financing or
contact we'll come back to this plot
point later bison acts menacing while
talking about real estate chun-li fights
off six guys while starving and
sleep-deprived then collapses after
murdering a man by dropping a shelving
unit full of power tools on to him
she is picked up by again who takes her
back to his place and trains her to make
fireballs and an extended training
montage and he tells chun-li that bison
is the person who kidnapped her father
and so chun-li starts spying on Bisons
team actually as a part of this he
explains that he used to be part of
shadow Lee Bisons
organization but he grew a conscience so
he started the order of the web to try
and repair the damage that he has done
as a criminal but he's only like 50
which would mean that these ancient
scrolls are younger than a New Kids on
the Block poster so the next 20 minutes
or so are largely concerned with Bisons
real estate conspiracy he is I guess
extorting the city of Bangkok into
selling him the Riverside slums so that
he can kick out all the residents
bulldoze the neighborhood and build a
series of luxury condos but I'm not sure
why he needs to do all this extorting
because this sounds like exactly the
kind of garbage move cities are already
more than willing to do also there's a
MacGuffin called the White Rose that
bison is trying to smuggle into the city
this subplot leads to chun-li following
Bisons
woman can't Anna into a nightclub where
we're going to put the movie on pause
and talk for a second about gays I have
talked in the past about the Kuleshov
effect the principle of montage and the
psychological mechanisms through which
editing creates meaning now gays
describes the act of looking in a filled
context we are principally concerned
with the gaze of the camera meaning what
the camera chooses to look at and how it
chooses to look at it no better are the
ideas of gaze and montage demonstrated
than when a film chooses to use its gaze
to express the gaze of a character
within the film which is itself a
situation manufactured to justify gazing
so Chumley's planned to get information
out of can Tana is to seduce her a plan
to which can't Anna is potentially
receptive because she's attracted to
women a detail that is communicated to
us the audience via the camera following
her gaze and gazing on the women in the
dance club this isn't necessarily
condemnation but I think it's useful and
instructive to actually break down the
why and how of this information exchange
how it is that we as an audience come to
understand that can't Anna is attracted
to women purely via the use of
juxtaposed images being aware of these
kinds of mechanisms makes us more alert
as film viewers more conscious of the
ways in which a film is steering our
attention and our emotions and in turn
making us better equipped to vocalize
the messages that media is presenting us
with in this case the way that the film
has chosen to justify staring at women's
asses by using a female character as the
agent of that staring anyway this
subplot ends with chun-li fighting can't
Anna in the bathroom and as she's
escaping from the nightclub she shoots
the man in the chest at point-blank
range so yeah he's dead in a scene
that's up there in the realms of where
did they think they were going with this
bison is using Kant Anna's dead body as
a punching bag because she'd already
said too much
all right strap in for a second because
this is where things really jump off the
rails like the punching bag scene is
definitely something but then
ghin fills in Bisons whole backstory so
in his youth as the orphan of some Irish
missionaries who died in Thailand he
used to just steal fish but crossfade
time jump to much later in life when
he's I guess no longer homeless he takes
his very pregnant new wife to a cave and
kills her by ripping their baby out
through her belly in order to put all
his goodness into the baby so that he
wouldn't have a conscience and would
only be pure evil we'll come back to
this one too evil guys attacked the
secret hideout and the stupidest way
possible they send in ninjas to fight
hand-to-hand when they have a rocket
launcher in the car both parts of that
are stupid but it does give us the best
line in the film I'll do it myself
in the explosion Gann dies then bison
hires Vega to kill chun-li and Vega
promptly gets his ass kicked
now this next scene chun-li physically
assaults a civilian for not giving up
private shipping manifest and get some
more information about the white rose
but for me the scene is more instructive
because of the sound
I haven't pointed this out up until now
but the dialogue in the film has
overwhelmingly been redubbed which is
actually part of why the performances
feel so flat and disjointed the emotion
of the face and lips just doesn't quite
match the sound that you're hearing also
there's a different character to the
dialogue that's recorded in a sound
booth versus the dialogue that's
recorded on set it's subtle but
pervasive now if you listen to this
guy's lines hear how they're kind of
mumbly and overlapping with a lot of
room noise and echoes I wouldn't be
surprised to find out that most of the
onset sound was like this which is why
there's so much dubbing like in this
scene what is this have to do with my
father many people wanted those
connections people a bison
a leader of shadow moving on with the
plot chun-li gets trapped and captured
bison kills her dad in front of her she
escapes but takes a grazing shot in a
market and manages to slip away once a
riot starts Jen shows up because he's
not dead just a dick uses magic powers
to heal her bullet wound in seconds and
she finally figures out how to make a
fireball returning to the dock she
threatens this guy again
there's a big fight at the docks again
fights Balrog they figure out that the
white roses Bisons daughter chun-li
knocks bison off a roof with a fireball
kills him in front of his daughter
buries her dad plants some sequal bait
credits roll
did you even notice the two supporting
characters that I cut from the plot
these two the Interpol agent and the
Thai detective no guess we didn't need
them his name's bison
I've tracked him through 11 major cities
on four continents and never come close
not once they actually take up a
substantial chunk of the screen time
they're a couple of cops in pursuit of
bison and his shadaloo organization but
mostly they just sit slightly off to the
side of the action or show up after
everything is over they're pretty much
just here for padding and innuendo we
should be more aggressive looks like you
got that down well unlike you I don't
lose my man all right let's start with
the whole abandoning your past life
story line the first major flaw in this
is that no one tries to stop Chumlee her
mother just died she's clearly in a
deeply vulnerable place in her life and
not one of these people friends or
extended family tries to intervene when
she quits her job and packs up her house
this isn't indicative of plot hole it's
indicative of a fundamental lack of
drama or conflict and this all ties into
another issue she doesn't actually
abandon everything she doesn't get up
and walk away from it all taking only
some bare essentials and living with the
poorest of society oh sure she sleeps in
an alley and skips out on showering but
at the end of the movie she's moving
right back into her multi-million dollar
Hong Kong mansion living on the streets
for a couple of weeks was probably
instructive but she was basically a
poverty tourist if she ever got tired of
living in a slum there was always a
mansion waiting back in Hong Kong she
sacrificed nothing this ties directly
into the character arc chun-li doesn't
really learn anything or change at the
start of the film she's a confident
spunky kind-hearted person as the film
progresses she dabbles in poverty
tourism kills three men in cold blood
without remorse and returns to her life
of wealth as a spunky kind-hearted
slightly more confident person now
that's not an irredeemable problem lots
of good movies have main characters who
don't learn or change all that much but
it is a problem when your movie opens
with the main character pondering how
they turned into the person they are
sometimes I wonder how I got to be the
way I am the writers have explicitly set
up a transformation story I used to be a
little girl who wanted to be a piano
player now I'm a cold-hearted killer who
murders people for the greater good I
used to be a selfish upper-class snob
but I learned the value of hard work
community and sacrifice these are the
kind of stories that we are very
literally being told to expect any
transformation contrast is deeply
compromised by the early scenes of the
film when her father is kidnapped now
the problem is not the existence of
these scenes but they're proportional
lengths within the film were shown that
she's been exposed to this criminal
world since she was a little girl and we
only spend the briefest time with her as
a civilian this is a really good example
of how movies need to function
emotionally and not just literally we
can look at the opening of the film and
extrapolate that logically everything
between her father being kidnapped and
her success as an adult was more or less
normal but we don't feel the respective
weight of these things because it's such
a tiny part of the opening her time as a
concert pianist feels more like a brief
interlude in a life of violence a hobby
that she took up to pass the time
waiting for revenge rather than the
normal world that she's pulled out of
and what little we see of her in that
stage of her life is basically the same
person we see at the end of the film the
only thing that changes is the number of
living parents and felony murders next
up is the whole thing where bison
transfers his goodness into a little
baby I have a couple problems with this
scene first and least important is that
the intensity and violence of the scene
is considerably out of place given the
tone and treatment of violence
throughout the rest of the film it's an
extremely jarring kick the dog scene
that's meant to show the audience just
how evil the bad guy is but I think it
becomes less effective because it's so
relatively extreme it's such a sharp
break from almost everything else that
it pulls you out to a place where it
stops being the actions of a character
and becomes the decisions of some
filmmakers
you're not thinking about the moment and
its place in the emotional tapestry of
the movie you're thinking about why the
people who made this made it the way
they did the only other scene that comes
close is where bison is using Kant
Anna's body as a punching bag while
everything else is sanitized bloodless
fantasy violence beyond that is the
implications of this scene on the
metaphysical world of the film so first
things that happen in movies don't need
to be true like characters can believe
something without that thing being
diegetic ly factual it's one thing for
this myth to exist for again to tell
chun-li this mystical rumor that he
heard but it's effectively confirmed
later in the film that his daughter is
in fact the vessel holding all the
goodness of his soul this means that in
the world of Street Fighter good and bad
are tangible products that can be
transferred from one person to another
while the implications on freewill and
morality are staggering most importantly
it does nothing to actually improve the
story at all it makes bison less
comprehensible it doesn't make his goals
any clearer we still have no idea what
he's up to what he's doing on a day to
day basis and what his end goal is it
actually makes it worse by offloading
the explanation onto supernatural evil
the screenwriters fall into the trap
where the villains actions are
tautologically justified by them being
the villain it's fine for melodrama raúl
juliá
understood that the day bison graced
your village was the most important day
of your life but for me it was Tuesday
but Legend of chun-li is trying to take
itself seriously there's one thing I
learned in the slums
when people are hungry there's nothing
they won't do
everyone has a price
there's a plot in here about buying up
waterfront property for redevelopment
but they're extorting the city board
into making the sale which makes no
sense was the board zoning the area as a
slum for purely altruistic reasons it's
like the writers couldn't decide if
bison should be using black magic
private military shady business
practices or a Chinatown style shakedown
so they tried to just squeeze them all
in it's hard to care about any of them
since the stakes are so vague the people
who live in the slums get kicked out
then vanished never to be seen or
mentioned again not that we ever really
connected with them in the first place
the big showdown at the end with
Interpol bison and Chumley doesn't even
have anything to do with the whole slum
buyout anyway and the plot line is never
resolved the only reason anyone cares
about the whiterose shipment is because
they think it might be a weapon
even though Bisons whole plan is pretty
much just capitalism to top it all off
the changes to the source material
actively make the story worse in her
original incarnations chun-li is
alternately an undercover cop or an
Interpol agent changing her from a cop
to a concert pianist does nothing to
raise the stakes or make the character
more relatable in fact that makes the
story hard to tell because you now have
to justify all kinds of crazy crap
that's super easy to hand wave if she
works for Interpol why is she in
Thailand
why does she know martial arts why does
she have combat training and not freak
out the first time someone pulls a gun
on her why does she care about the legal
front of a criminal organization all of
this action nonsense is just explained
in one line if she works for Interpol
the character conflict comes baked in
when she confronts bison does she stick
with her training and let the courts
bring him to justice
or does she extract revenge and kill him
herself when she meets again does she
stick with Interpol with its superior
resources but strict rules and
expectations or become a vigilante and
joined the order of the web instead were
asked to believe that a concert pianist
who learned kung-fu as a kid is going to
be willing to throw herself at a
armed international criminal
organization and not wind up as Jane Doe
floating down the river they wanted to
legitimize the video game adaptation and
they screwed it up with an awful script
every single problem with this movie
comes back to the script the characters
frequently make decisions based on
information they don't have because the
script needs to get them somewhere the
villains are an indistinct Mass made of
every bad guy trope possible resulting
in an antagonist that's too confusing to
take seriously and entire chunks of the
film are flat-out useless to the story
the funny thing is that they failed so
hard that even when talking about video
game movies a sub-genre that is peppered
with examples that plumb the depths of
shoddy hilarious and hilariously shoddy
filmmaking that they made something most
notable for how forgettable it is you're
not a schoolgirl anymore really in all
the agonizing over when video game
movies are going to finally be good we
missed that they already peaked with
Super Mario Brothers in 1993 mike-mike
up these Mario's around the side
[Music]